is Gary V being short-sighted so I got a
great question for one of my YouTube
fans love you guys nhp are men who wrote
in the say I just watched Gary v's
newest ass video and he said he never
self examines he was asked about his
weaknesses and he said I really
struggled to think about what I'm bad at
because I spend all my time thinking
about what I'm great at and those are a
lot of things is that short-sighted so
first of all let me say I'm a huge Gary
Vee fan I'm a subscriber to his channel
i watch almost all the videos that come
out I've commented on almost all of the
asked videos that he's made I think he
adds a lot of value to the
entrepreneurial world in terms of adding
strategies and specific tactics that you
can use to apply to your business on the
execution side as well as giving you
motivation it in hustle to want to go
out and accomplish your goals now in
terms of answering this question you
know Gary bees had a lot of success in
his life he's built and sold businesses
he's a best-selling author he has a big
following he says that he's happy so if
he's had a lot of success he's reaching
his goals he's happy who are we to judge
if he's being short-sighted or not if
you're trying to make Gary V a better
person then you know what happens with
unsolicited advice right it barely gets
taken so the real question that becomes
is this a strategy that is short-sighted
for you or not I know if I'm thinking
about myself I would reframe in a little
bit instead of talking about weaknesses
i would talk about lack of passion see I
believe that any weakness can be
overcome with passion if you love
something you can get better at it and
learn it to be successful when you start
anything you suck at it because this
your first time in it but if you have a
lot of passion for you can get better
with practice and with time when I first
started making videos I sucked at it
when i first started salsa dancing I
sucked at it when i had my child and I
was the first time father I sucked at
being a dad I was constantly worried
about if I was doing the right thing or
not and through practice and passion and
experience I got better but there's also
going to be those things that you're
good at that you have talented but
you're not passionate about and those
are the things that in my view you have
to drop as well because it's only
through passion
you're going to realize your goals and
accomplish your big dreams so when I
started making these videos I did
everything myself I was in front of the
camera and behind the camera doing all
the entity I learned how to use movie
maker and then I learned how to use
Camtasia and every time I did a video I
got better and better and better what
started off as a real weakness for me
could have been a big strength if I was
passionate about making videos and
learning how to edit but I wasn't I
found that I love being in front of the
camera much more than being behind it
and so for my business to grow I had to
spend more time being in front and not
being behind and I look for ways to
eliminate autumn a delegate the things
that I'm not passionate about in my
business so I hired Christina who loves
doing video and who's great at it and
having her on the team has helped my
business grow so I find that by paying
attention to maybe not my weaknesses but
paying attention to the things that I'm
not passionate about and then
eliminating automating and delegating
them way I'm able to spend my time on
the high productivity hi passion high
value things that can help my business
grow you need to figure out if my
approach works for you or your Eevee's
approach works for you or maybe neither
of them work for you the only way for
you to figure out of that short-sighted
advice for you or not is to test it try
it and see if it works if examining the
things that you're weak on or the things
that you're not passionate about help
you grow then do it regularly and if
they don't then stop it immediately but
either way take action and believe for
those are watching I'd love to know what
you think about it do you focus on your
weaknesses do you focus on things that
you're not passionate about and try to
change your life accordingly if you do
leave a comment below let's get a
discussion going on I'd love to hear
from you and if you're not yet a
subscriber of the channel the see more
videos like this click that subscribe
button thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon South improvement
books are like fitness books they never
work on their own what you need is a
trainer that's Evan get the newsletter
you